m
bienvenue à tous pour cette deuxième
édition du masters international de
pelote basque
c'est cette édition ça commence
d'inconnus et déjà les premières
compétitions
nous a parlé de nos messieurs aux
senteurs à peine né vaut mieux parler
dans le micro à commencer par willy
mucha willy cette manifestation cas ce
qu'elle représente deuxième édition
cette manifestation représente beaucoup
de choses déjà
on est chez nous on est chez nous et ça
nous fait plaisir d'accueillir les
étrangers l'espagne les français de
différentes régions notamment dans les
grands ce sens vous montez dans le
chaudron exactement exactement c'est ce
qui a fait ce qu'il ya de mieux
même en championnat du monde n'a pas un
plateau de pelotaris de cinq ans dit
adieu à ce que tu confirmes du mois
sylvain pas tout simplement le meilleur
joueur du monde c'est ça servian du
monde professionnel
alors moi je me sens pas du tout
étranger ici on est tellement bien
accueilli que gm se joue à domicile
c'est un plaisir c'est hyper bien
préparé je veux dire au niveau de
l'installation de tout ce qui est
préparation avant match pendant le match
c'est génial donc on est chez vraiment
chez les pros ici aussi
effectivement le plateau est juste
superbe c'est la première fois qu'on
arrive à mélanger les pros et des
amateurs
c'est pour ça qu'on nous disait que le
plateau et même mieux que sur une scène
championnat du monde
c'est ce qu'on doit payer au premier
match là tu es serbe ce premier match ne
mériterait très fier parce que là on a
mis nos petits jeunes un petit peu sur
le devant de la scène donc germé mathieu
ont pris une marche tout à l'heure
contre bien ladrière et benoît est
arrivé car en 2014
vraiment on est fier de vous attendez le
bruit c'est ce qu'on voulait il faut de
l'ambiance on est au chaudron il faut de
l'ambiance
en sortant appelle le 112 ça représente
quoi ça sert de saisie paris 16ème
complètement inverse une habitude de
vivre ça à l'extérieur
là il fait la deuxième édition master
n'y faisait coup double par rapport les
gens il connaît pas la pelote cette
icône et la pelote ici je te connais pas
la flotte dans le monde et là c'est ce
qui fait d'eux venu ici actuellement je
sais pas qui veut répondre mais pourquoi
venir
pourquoi venir toute cette semaine vous
voit pour plusieurs raisons dont on a
bien évidemment le plateau sportif pour
les gens qui aiment le sport on peut le
voir c'est spectaculaire il ya de la
vitesse il ya du bruit il ya de
l'ambiance donc pour le plateau sportif
on pourra pas rêver mieux
et puis tout simplement aussi parce
qu'il ya toutes les animations derrière
on peut recevoir toutes les familles les
collègues de boulot en famille ça touche
toutes les populations de tous les âges
tous les amoureux du sport dans lequel a
pour tous les goûts
donc voilà pourquoi venir faire un petit
tour en chaudron dans la semaine depuis
deux mois
avec vous on est juste
comment vous avez fait on va tous ses
soutiens c'est assez la pression s'est
nettement repris bon je crois que c'est
tout simplement grâce à eux parce que
nos sportifs depuis depuis plusieurs
années bien ramène des médailles d'or
d'un peu partout de peu partout en
france et un métropole et dans le monde
donc tout simplement grâce à eux on a le
soutien de tous les amoureux de la
réunion tous les amoureux du sport
réunionnais et des collectivités bien
évidemment le conseil départemental qui
nous est de chaque année qui nous permet
aussi de voyager à travers les billets
d'avion tout ça bien évidemment
financièrement et puis à la cérémonie
d'ouverture aujourd'hui on va retrouver
nos élus donc c'est ça qui est ça qui va
faire aussi une belle fête tous ensemble
et
qu'est ce que ça change le procès
sachant de l'avenir de certains jeunes
comme des professionnels oui
effectivement déjà dès la première
édition n'a eu on a eu une augmentation
importante de des membres des licenciés
donc du coup les jeunes à travers ce à
travers ce spectacle
ebay saluait intérêt s'il veut venir
essayer et du coup après ils trouvent
leur compte ils commencent à avoir un
bon niveau et c'est comme ça former les
jeunes quoi lecture j'aimerais juste
quelque chose
le mec est assumé à droite là c'est
c'est douche par le 12 je préparais de
janot aussi cédé grand monsieur de la
pelote qui sont leur nom est connu à
travers le monde entier
donc forcément quand on est un jeune du
chaudron on boit on a tous des modèles
on a tous des modèles dans la vie et
quand on voit un grand on croise de
temps en temps comme ça du japon ou
d'autres comme willy également on a
envie de devenir comme eux aussi le
sport c'est serra le sport est un
vecteur et l'homme
même pour s'en sortir dans la vie si le
super écolo et cdh est super modèle pour
les jeunes non moi je voudrais les
remercier aussi c'est pour ça qu'on est
là aujourd'hui nous dont je le connais
depuis très longtemps jalons aussi et on
est vraiment fiers aujourd'hui d'être
dans ce gymnase qui porte leur nom et de
pouvoir se confronter à eux parce que
c'est ce qui se fait de mieux dans la
pelote tout simplement voilà j'ai même
plaisir et on va finir sur ces mots
bravo bravo à tous bravo mouvement
sportif
donc venez voir cette manifestation
le master international de palau glace
c'est toute cette semaine et boire une
mouvance lortie bonne manifestation